اوكرانيا للناتو. وبولندا تضع
يدها في الجرح الروسي. والكرملين
تحملوا عواقب افعالكم. الناتو
يستعرض عضلاته في المحيط. وبعد
استهداف اراضيها. روسيا ترد
بقوة. والحرب تنتقل الى البحر.
فما ذنب الاسماك؟ وسويسرا تترك
سلاحها وتعلن العودة للحياد.
وايران تفتح الابواب على
مصراعيها امام التفتيش النووي.
حرب المحيطات تندلع. في البر
تدور معارك طحن العظام. وفي الجو
حيث لا رحمة امام الطائرات. واما
في البحر فتندلع الاشتباكات بين
حين واخر. لتنصب الحرب
الاوكرانية نفسها حرب في القرن
الحادي والعشرين. نعم يا سادة.
وبعد ان طالت المعارك على البر
وازدادت خسائر الطرفين حولت كييف
بوصلتها الى البحر لتعلن الدفاع
الروسي ان نظام كييف هاجم
السفينة ايفان خورس التابعة
للبحرية الروسية بسفن مسيرة في
منطقة مضيق البوسفور. مشيرة الى
ان طاقم السفينة صد الهجوم
بنجاح. ليتمكنوا من تدمير جميع
الزوارق المسيرة بنيران عادية.
وذلك وفق بيان الوزارة الروسية.
هذا ما تقوم به السفينة ايفان
خوروس بمهام لضمان سلامة تشغيل
خط انابيب الغاز السيل التركي
والسيل الازرق في المنطقة
الاقتصادية الخالصة لجمهورية
تركيا. وفي البحر تستمر المعارك
لترتفع حدة التوترات بين الغرب
وروسيا. حيث ابحرت حاملة
الطائرات جيرالد فورد. وهي اكبر
حاملة طائرات في العالم الى
اوسلو في اول مشاركة لسفينة
امريكية من هذا النوع. فيما
اعتبر استعراضا لقوة الناتو وذلك
في ظل تصاعد ازمة التوتر بين
الحلف وروسيا بسبب حرب اوكرانيا.
ليقول الجيش النرويجي ان السفينة
وطاقمها سيجرون تدريبات مع
القوات المسلحة النرويجية على
طول ساحل البلاد في الايام
المقبلة. الرد الروسي جاء سريعا.
حين نددت السفارة الروسية في
اوسلو بزيارة حاملة الطائرات
الامريكية. واضافت انه لا توجد
مشكلات في الشمالي تتطلب حلا
عسكريا ولا قضايا تحتاج تدخلا
خارجيا. اي انهم يتسائلون ما
الذي جاء بحاملة الطائرة
الامريكية الى هنا. فبماذا ستجيب
واشنطن? وبينما تتواصل الحرب
الاوكرانية يزداد سعيرها. هنا
صرح مصدر عسكري مطلع ان منظومة
الدفاع الجوي الصاروخية الروسية
اس ثلاثمائة وخمسين في تياز
اسقطت ولاول مرة طائرة حربية
اوكرانية بشكل دون مشاركة بشرية.
حيث تم اكتشاف هدف جوي اوكراني.
ومتابعته واسقاطه دون اوامر من
البشر. وذلك بحسب وكالة نوفوستي.
وهنا يلجأ الروس الى خطة ماكرة
تستنزف الاسلحة الاوكرانية
والغربية في اوكرانيا. حيث
يستخدم الجيش الروسي في منطقة
العملية العسكرية الخاصة مسيرة
جوية ذات تصميم مميز. لخداع
الدفاعات الجوية الاوكرانية.
وذلك لانها مصنوعة من الخشب
الرغوي ويتم تجميعها بواسطة شريط
لاصق ليطلق الاوكران ذخيرتهم
التي تعادل الالاف او مئات
الالاف من الدولارات مقابل قطعة
خشبية بلاستيكية. فيال هذا المكر
الروسي الخبي. ومع التقدم الروسي
والخسائر الاوكرانية لا زال طباخ
بوتيني بريجوجان. يسبح عكس
الطيار. حيث قال رئيس مجموعة
فاجنار. ان اكثر من عشرين الفا
من قواته لقوا حتفهم المعركة
الطويلة للسيطرة على باخموت.
وذلك خلافا لما اعلنت عنه الدفاع
الروسي التي قالت انها خسرت
قرابة الستة الاف جندي في
باخموت. فهل يقول الحقيقة ام ان
له مآرب اخرى? لتأخذنا الاحداث
قليلا نحو الاراضي الروسية. وبعد
ان تم استهداف مقاطعة بيلجوراد
الروسية بالمسيرات. اضافة
لمحاولة مجموعة من الجنود اختراق
العمق الروسي. قال وزير الدفاع
الروسي ان سترد بطريقة قاسية جدا
على اقتحام الاوكران وهنا عادت
كييف لتنفي ذلك وعلى لسان نائبة
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني التي اكدت
ان بلادها لا تقوم باي عملية
داخل الاراضي الروسية مشيرة الى
ان من قام بذلك هم مواطنون روس
مستاءون من نظام بوتين بسبب حربه
على اوكرانيا على حد تعبيرها.
بينما زعمت مجموعة روسية مناهضة
رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين.
تطلق على نفسها اسم فيلق
المتطوعين الروس ان اعضاءها من
المقاتلين الروس واكدت توغلها في
وتمكنها من الاستيلاء على مدرعة
للجيش الروسي. وعلى ذات الصعيد
وصل السباحة عكس التيار الروسي.
حيث حذر بريجوجن من ان روسيا قد
تواجه ثورة مماثلة لثورة عام الف
وتسعمائة وسبعة عشر. وتخسر الحرب
في اوكرانيا ما لم تتعامل النخبة
مع الحرب ليضيف قائلا ان
اوكرانيا تعد لهجوم مضاد يهدف
الى دحر القوات الروسية الى حدود
ما قبل عام الفين واربعة عشر
عندما ضمت روسيا شبه جزيرة
القرم. من جانبه اكد الامين
العام لحلف الناتو ينس ستولتوم
بارك ان مسألة انضمام اوكرانيا
الى الحلف قبل انتهاء النزاع
المسلح مع روسيا ليست مطروحة على
الطاولة. والى خارج اوكرانيا
تتوسع الحرب الروسية وبولندا قد
تكون الحصان هذه المرة اذا
طالتها نيران بوتين. حيث كان
نائب وزير الدفاع الوطني
البولندي السابق الجنرال
فلاديمير قد قال في تصريحات
سابقة ان بولندا تستعد لانقلاب
مسلح في بيلاروسيا والمشاركة في
الدعم العسكري وفق ما اوردته
وكالة نوفوستي الروسية. ليرد
متحدث الكرملين ديمتري بيسكوف
على الفور قائلا بولندا دولة
معادية لنا. اود ان اذهب الى
ابعد من ذلك. انه لسوء الحظ فان
القيادة البولاندية تدخل الان
فعليا في هستيريالها بروسيا.
مضيفا ان بولندا تريد التدخل في
دولة مجاورة واردف بيسكوف. ان
هذه الدولة المجاورة في اشارة
لبيلا روسيا هي الشريك والحليف
والدولة الشقيقة لنا. وبطبيعة
الحال فروسيا ملتزمة بضمان امن
ميتسك ومن بيلاروسيا الى سويسرا
دولة الحياد في العالم التي كانت
قد خرجت عن حيادها قليلا. لتعلن
اليوم السويسرية رغبتها في بيع
خمس وعشرين دبابة ليو بارد اثنان
غير مستخدمة لديها الى الشركة
الالمانية المصنعة لوضعها في
متناول الجيش الالماني او
الشركاء في حلف الناتو وذلك بعد
تعهد برلين بعدم نقل الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا بناء على طلب
سويسرا. برأيكم ما الذي جعل
سويسرا تعود الى حيادها مرة
اخرى. الاحداث والتطورات. اكد
البيت الابيض انه لا ينوي في
الوقت راهن اللجوء الى المادة
الرابعة عشر من الدستور الامريكي
لرفع سقف الدين ومنع تخلف
الولايات المتحدة عن السداد.
المنافس الرئيسي لترامب على ورقة
الحزب الجمهوري ديت سانتيس يعلن
ترشحه رسميا لسباق البيت الابيض.
اكدت ايران استعدادها للتعاون
التام مع المفتشين الدوليين.
وذلك عقب الكشف عن انشاءات جديدة
قرب منشآت النووية. وكانت
اسرائيل لوحت بتحرك عسكري ضد
ايران مع استمرار رفع لنسب تخصيب
اليورانيوم. بولندا تشد الانظار
الروسية نحوها. فهل تتحول ضربات
الروس ايضا نحو الاراضي
البولاندية?